so i actually sit down on the toilet
bowl and i just lift one leg up and i
just try to find a hole
[Music]
all right what's up i'm chris distefano
i am here to answer the internet for the
third time the only other one who's done
it three times is a bella danger and we
both love [ __ ] would you rather pee
every time you stand up or poop
every time you sit down well i gotta be
honest with you i genuinely feel like i
absolutely have prostate cancer because
i have to pee
24 7.
the amount of pee that's going to come
out of my body right now is as soon as
this is over i'm gonna wet my pants so i
would say every time i'm standing i feel
like i'm have to pee and to be honest
dude every time i sit down the fart that
i ripped the fart and you know what
you should even though he seems like a
nice guy i would get rid of this
cameraman because you got to know when
chrissy cares in the building you start
rolling because i farted out of the top
of my ass crack how
a top of the cracker is very rare and
you missed it
so shame on you where's the homeless
pimp
yes it went up it was like a [ __ ] jed
it was like a jazz tune beethoven was
like i heard that i'd rather i'd rat
because i know what it feels like to
every time i stand up have to pee
because it's i have prostate cancer aka
chlamydia
so i'll say so i know what that's like
so i'll say every time i sit down i i
poop because that's really not that bad
because you just wear a diaper and my
ass is fat enough anyway you can't see
it i have a lunch lady asked is sex with
conjoined twins a threesome yes well it
depends if you have sex
with
let me ask you a question now it depends
where they are conjoined
because if they're conjoined at the head
and they're sharing a brain
then
i think it's one it's one brain two
[ __ ] do you need two heads or two
genitalia that's the question i'm gonna
say because it comes all from the brain
and i've gotten very spiritual uh shout
out tony robbins um you're taking all my
money and i'm gladly giving it to you
speaking of a big head jesus christ i
mean
get a reduction i would say i'm more
spiritual about it i would say that it's
i think sex is from the brain so i would
say one brain two [ __ ] i would say
yes if it's conjoined at the head i
would say yes i am having a threesome
with them uh i'm sorry i'm not having
threesome with them if it's not
conjoined at the head then i would say
yes i'm having a threesome with them
that's what i'd say would you rather go
to a circus alone or give your mom a
foot massage i'll say
i'd rather
give my mom
a foot massage just because she has
really little feet and it won't take
that long i mean my mom's feet are so
small she should be in the circus i mean
this lady has corny feet where i'm like
how do you even stand up you i mean her
feet are so tight she looks like a doll
so i'd like to massage her little baby
asian feet then go to a circus alone
because the problem is with me going to
a circus alone is i'd want to blow the
guy on stilts
are there sacred days when you refuse to
masturbate funerals tragedies religious
holidays etc the only day i didn't
masturbate on was 9 11.
but i i didn't masturbate not the whole
day i just
i didn't masturbate until about 11
o'clock and then i said you know what
this is for the people we lost
and i dropped them for the homies who
passed away because that's what they
would want me to do if i died in 9 11 i
said you know what i want this little 17
year old pervert just jerk off a little
bit because i'm having a rough day
so you guys can air that one or not
yeah that's totally your call i just you
know in the brain out the mouth that's
how i roll would you have sex with a
dead person for five minutes if you get
your laundry done and folded magically
for the rest of your life well i mean
would um see the thing is laundry too
everybody
is all the laundry in the house every
all the laundry even pimp everything
everybody's getting lunch but all i have
to do is have sex with a dead person
well i got news for you the last seven
years of my relationship have felt like
i'm having sex with a dead person
so
and i do get my laundry done all the
time by my the laundry peep the laundry
mat on staten island shout out wish wash
laundry on victory boulevard i mean talk
it you guys gotta be from south korea
because you're a great people but yeah
dude i would say absolutely have i'd
have sex with a dead person for five
minutes because i know what it feels
like and here's the thing about me is i
can still come pretty quick off two
pumps off a [ __ ] carcass would you
rather wear high heels or a belly shirt
well as i've said my feet are so
sprained and broken and decrepit that
they already look like they're formed
for high heels and a belly shirt for me
would be bad news dude i've got an any
belly button that no matter how much i
wash it just always smells like salt and
vinegar potato chips because it's too
far in i mean it's it's on my colon
that's how it is
so
yeah i'll get a colonoscopy like you
have cancer like now dude i just got an
innie
it's not a polyp so i'd rather i guess
i'd rather wear high heels because i've
worn high heels multiple times in my
life for costumes and dares and stuff
but i've worn yeah dude i like to throw
them on a little bit that's the only way
i can get horny these days would you
rather fight a kangaroo or look like sam
cassell i mean sam cassell is brutal
holy [ __ ] he's [ __ ] i mean he's one
of those guys like he has to know like
if you're like sam you're ugly as [ __ ]
he'd be like yeah i obviously like what
do you think dude like he had to be good
at basketball because he had probably
looked at me and was like what did i do
to you jesus i mean he's brutal he's a
brutal looking guy but i still would
rather look like him than fight a
kangaroo because i have a very very like
strong fear of being eaten alive and
killed by an animal um so i don't want
to fight i don't want to fight a
kangaroo kangaroo could kill you i think
a kangaroo would absolutely dude i kid
they [ __ ] they kick you no more
absolutely dude i got a paper chin and
paper hands baby that's how i do it i
lose my bitcoins i'll get punched in
face get knocked unconscious and get
mauled to death by a kangaroo also i
don't want to die in [ __ ] australia
you know what i mean like i don't want
to do that you know what if you if i
could find a kangaroo in brooklyn i
might do it because at least if i die
you know what i mean i'll die in the
neighborhood i don't want to get my body
[ __ ] back on you know underneath a
spirit airlines flight like a scumbag
and then somebody accidentally hits the
wrong button my [ __ ] lifeless corpse
winds up in the pacific ocean like a
dick and then the ghost me comes by and
[ __ ] me what's better being a cowboy
or a pirate
i would say
i would say what's better is i think
being a pirate i think being a pirate uh
would be better because then you can get
away with more you know you're on the
high seas you're on the seven seas um
you know you get treasure and booty i
mean what's being a cowboy dude you know
you put on a a gay shirt and a hat you
ride around a horse with a rope like a
lasso like it's all it's all a little
gay being a cowboy where a pirate i
don't feel pirates as gay
i don't feel that being a pirate is as
gay as being a cowboy that's why i'd
rather go uh be a pirate because i
really want to shock him when i come out
as the first really [ __ ] gay pirate
would you rather a [ __ ] yourself every
time you come b get a boner every time
you talk to a dude well
[Music]
so that's an easy one for me i'm live
and be
[ __ ] and and the thing is it's gotten to
the point for me now where my mind has
gotten so warped that i can only come
when i [ __ ] myself so or be [ __ ] on so
that's an easy one it's b would you
switch your penis size with your foot
size
um let's see i'm a size 12
let let me ask you this
here's an addendum though
switch this penis size with the foot
size do i have warts or no warts
on both because you can get warrants
either way
i would say i would say no i wouldn't
switch my penis size with my foot size
um i would i like my foot i think i feel
like size 12 is good and i have i have a
decent decent penis six and a half seven
i have oh you're over seven i think i'm
over seven soft i'm i will be i will
tell you though when i my penis is soft
it's a it's a little like it's no it's
it's really bad so my soft penis is like
just the head yeah it's brutal my soft
penis looks like sam cassell would you
rather your girlfriend get a
notification every time you watch porn
with the description or a notification
of where you are at all times um i would
rather her get a notification
um every time i've watched porn because
i'm slowly trying to exit the
relationship and if she saw my porn
history she know what i'm really into
and it don't have what you have do you
wipe standing or sitting i absolutely
wipe sitting because i got long balls so
if i stand up and my balls dip down then
i'm gonna have to move my sack out of
the way to wipe my [ __ ] so i actually
sit down on the toilet bowl and i just
lift one leg up and i just try to find a
hole and i just try to wipe something
and then i drop it in the toilet i never
get up from the bathroom and i also
never look i just do a flush because i'm
pre here's the thing with me is i
is i always wipe
sitting down
because it's it's it's it's i don't like
to stand up because i got long balls and
i like and when i when when i'm wiping
my butthole i i always just wipe and
throw the paper in and i always flush
because i'm too scared to look because
i'm almost 100 sure there will be blood
in the toilet so i've so i so that's why
is i'm like you know what i'd rather not
deal with the fact that i have [ __ ]
cancer i'd rather just sit down and then
die when i died
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications however make sure you
click thumbs up for the like hit that
bell icon